Okay.
We are alive. This is definitely the
first time we're doing this intro.
Um ignore any previous clips to the
contrary. Those are AI generated.
This is going to be the start of the
Puffer 5 dev sprint.
I think that in less than 2 weeks we can
get the core algorithmic component done
for this update.
The specific method that we're going to
be investigating here
is very high confidence because the type
of problem that it addresses
it seems that fundamentally you can't
really address it in any other way.
To give you a a sort of a quick example
of the problem
let's say you have a 2-hour task
you get reset every time you fail it.
Um
every single time you make a mistake at
the end you have to redo the whole
thing. So it's very, very inefficient.
This is true in the real world as well,
but in Sim we can shortcut this.
And uh this is likely to give us a
massive, massive boost
to the convergence speed of our
algorithm.
I will go over the detailed version of
this in a moment.
We do have that.
Um
a couple things about the way that I
have set this up
cuz I figured I would have some fun with
uh with this research sprint and also
set it up to be as productive as I
possibly can.
Y'all can join me on this plan if you uh
if you're a game.
Morning starts with a 10K run followed
by some quick compound weight lifting
or some quick compound weights, not
Olympic lifts.
Uh followed by quick breakfast followed
by most likely a 7-to-8-hour stream.
Uh and then dinner thereafter and
retired early for the evening to do it
again.
And very little otherwise going on.
So, hopefully this will put me in a good
mental spot to make good decisions on
the algorithm choices. I think the
overall algorithm is pretty well set up,
but there are some specific choices that
um, you know, making them sooner rather
than later and getting details correct
will save a ton and ton of time and
allow us to do this quite soon.
Hey Anish.
That's good to hear, man.
That's good to hear. I'm glad you're
doing better.
Welcome to the five stream.
Okay.
Let me go over the algorithm plan first
a little bit.
I wrote this.
Um, I had I basically just had Codex
like I asked like, "Hey, is there
anything unclear here?" and then I just
went and fixed everything until it was
clear. So, but I wrote this.
And
uh
There are a few new hyper parameters.
There's an additional prioritized replay
buffer. There's a warm-up time. There's
the fraction of environments that are
going to be using this new curriculum
learning method. And then there's a
buffer of states of a fixed size.
You're going to need this ring buffer
for states. You're going to need a
buffer for advantages and you're going
to need an index buffer.
The way that the algorithm works is
the first time you do rollouts
or the first step, the first time step
every time you do rollouts, if the
warm-up buffer isn't full yet,
then you're going to put all of those
initial states into the buffer.
Uh
but once it is full, you're only going
to put a certain fraction of the
environment states into the buffer.
And the rest of them are going to have
their state set
using prioritized experience replay
sampling over the existing state buffer.
You have a bunch of previously recorded
states, you're going to sample from
them, and you're going to sample ones
more often that have high absolute
advantage estimate. So, these should be
high information states.
During training, you compute your
advantage across all the segments. This
is going to be used to update the
priority of the buffer.
And you are going to sample segments
from the the current data buffer.
This is basically exactly as before. It
still uses prioritized replay, but it's
a different prioritized replay buffer.
And we're going to also make sure that
this is compatible with Puffer 4 if you
just set one of the hypers to zero.
We're going to do this on mazes. I've
already ported mazes to be state
settable and tested that it trains
correctly under Puffer 4.
Keep everything deterministic. We're
going to ignore multi-agent for now cuz
it's a pain in the ass.
Running in weights will not be streamed
as well. I do not have a practical way
to do that, and also I need some damn
time to myself.
But um
No, I'm in Palo Alto
doing that whole thing. I guess I can
share the Strava or whatever if you all
really want me to.
It's a really nice hilly course though
as well. It's got like
I think 700 ft elevation gain for the
course, maybe.
>> Okay, so this is the basic of it.
Um
because everybody always asks me about
the damn language models even when I'm
like trying to focus on cool stuff, I'm
going to address that now, and then I'm
just going to refer people towards the
start of this stream, rough timestamp,
whatever this is. Um
5 minutes into the stream, 6 minutes
into the stream. All right.
We are going to be using Codex for this.
We're not going to be vibe coding [ __ ]
like a [ __ ]
Um
I'm starting with this precise spec.
I'm going to be editing this. This was
generated based on the algorithm
description that I wrote.
I'm going to be editing this a whole
bunch
both manually and with Codex at a high
level
um until I have every single variable
allocation, function, kernel, etc.
nicely how I want it.
And then I'm going to have it implement
this in very small isolated changes that
I'm going to be reviewing manually and
editing as well to make sure it doesn't
make a mess of our nice code base.
And this is also why I am wide awake
today because
um I want to make sure that I don't get
lazy with this.
Yes, Tim. So, we're storing raw state.
The state is not used as the heuristic
for selection. That will be advantage.
So, you have a one-dimensional advantage
estimate. You don't need any down
sampling. You don't need any heuristics.
That is the key difference from Go
Explorer.
And you are storing the raw state
because that is how you set the state
back to a specific thing. So, unlike Go
Explorer, we're not going to rely on
deterministic resets and then stepping
all the way back to whatever state we
want to set. That's incredibly
inefficient. We are instead going to be
relying on setting directly to the
target state. And the key realization
of this is that we can always make our
sims this way because we're writing our
hyper sims ourselves anyways.
Okay, I will share the Strava, but I
think I will share the Strava after the
2 weeks. If you all remind me because I
don't want to like leak my live
location, basically.
All right, so let's start now. We're
good?
I think we're good.
Yeah, we're doing This is going to be 60
km per week starting.
And probably will ramp up a little bit
up to maybe like 70 or 80 by the end.
I think it has to be void star.
We'll figure out maybe we can make it
static later, but that's kind of tricky.
And well, this will be the first time of
many, I'm sure, for the stream.
Refer you to about 6 minutes into the
start. I addressed um
code tools and I'm just going to refer
everybody to that.
It's just a little bit of lifting, Tim.
I mean, I'm also Oh, yeah, I forgot the
part where this is also on like a
thousand plus calorie cut.
Um so, the lifting is basically just to
make sure I'm maintaining strength.
It's basically like, you know,
reasonably light breakfast, light
dinner, no lunch.
I already have the algorithm skeleton,
Jess. Like, the algorithm is already
well defined. This is now implementation
level.
Again,
6 minutes into the stream.
Like you'll basically see from the work
how I'm using stuff. This is not going
to be vibe coded [ __ ]
Reuse existing prio buffer.
I believe we can do that.
Um there are several uncertainties in
the core algorithm liberty. This is
brand new research. So the biggest
challenge is going to be making sure
that if stuff doesn't work like
isolating implementation bugs versus
um problems with algorithm, which is why
we need very high confidence
end-of-test.
Yes, this is based for puffer five.
I think that this thing is going to be
powerful enough to solve about half of
the remaining problems in the field.
It will require that you have a custom
sim to take full advantage of it.
And that your Sim be written in a
certain way,
but it's in a way that is amenable to
very high perf and not very complicated.
We will have to refactor every single
inven puffer a little bit um to
accommodate this. So, obviously, we're
going to only do that if this is like
really solid.
There will also be a fallback mode that
will essentially just run the puffer for
algorithm.
And that will fail uh that will be
handled gracefully.
>> him it's the idea is the key insight
from go explore is
the amount of improvement that you can
get from using state sets. The specific
sampling mechanism is going to be a lot
closer to what we have currently in
popper and then we're also going to be
using advantage as this signal of
information.
Is there pseudo code somewhere of the
idea? No, you can go back a few minutes
in the stream though. I explained like
the base algorithm.
Um, this is a new algorithm. We're not
implementing anything existing.
Oh, nice Jess.
Uh, he does have calm changes. Like I
don't know if I've merged them. He does
have calm changes.
Uh, there should be a PR open.
Might I I might have merged it. I
forget.
>> Go popper.
How about go pop?
We should probably
Yeah, we should probably pull
Still not sure with these kernels if we
need all of this.
I mean, this will be the main thing
we'll have to figure. The good news is
this is not very many.
I think this is just a copy. We can
probably make this into a more generic
scatter
if we need to.
Let me think of the order of operations
here.
We'll see if they Yeah, we'll do the VEC
changes first.
And then we'll do the allocations.
And then we'll do the buffer, like the
the algo changes. So, basically
they shouldn't break anything at all
until we start getting into the actual
like final bits, which it'd only be a
couple hundred lines of code, I would
think. Maybe a little bit more.
Yeah, I've gotten a lot better with my
time estimates on stuff though, Tim.
Like okay, buffer five took
Buffer five took 50% longer than I
anticipated, but we
we did like more more double what was
planned in that update originally.
I mean Puffer 4, yeah.
Puffer 5 is going to be hopefully quick
update.
Well, to be fair, we did most of what
was going to be Puffer 6 in Puffer 4.
So, now it's like 5 is intended to be a
much shorter update that's focused on a
small set of algorithmic changes and
some cleanup.
Uh it's a heck of a lot more than SB3
and OpenAI Gym.
So, SB3 is a bunch of algorithms
implemented in a really bloated slow
way, and they're standard algorithms.
This is state-of-the-art our algorithm
based on our latest research with
comprehensive backing and evidence in
the shortest, simplest, fastest way
possible.
OpenAI Gym is a big heavy bloated API
for environments that also includes
threading and vectorization, but it's
really crappy and slow.
In our case, we have a whole bunch of
environments with a very very minimal
interface,
no big bloated API, and a simple fast
vectorization back end all designed from
the ground up.
And uh it's all open source. We have
tons of environments from contributors.
We build our own. We do our own custom
research. We come up with our own custom
architecture work.
We do pretty much everything.
Now, this is not CodeX watch party. This
is
I mean, I would Does anybody know how to
fix this stupid like sandbox fail
thingy?
4 was intended to be a much smaller not
replace torch. Like it was intended to
just be torch C++ with a few custom
kernels. Possibly the new architecture,
but also possibly just like BFloat16
LSTM support. And um
like really not that much else. The goal
was only 10 mil steps per second.
And we ended up hitting 20 million with
full custom everything. Only 1,000 lines
more code than the torch version was
going to end up being.
It's not every problem. Like it's not a
good choice for stuff that has strong
language and vision priors in
particular.
But
I do think it's going to be very useful
in core scientific progress including in
biological applications and that's
actually one of my main interests.
I'm not going too deep into anything
like
any of the really tough applications
just yet because I kind of want to get
reinforcement learning to a state where
this is like really stable, solid,
consistent tech first. And I think we're
less than a year away
from being there. Where we can actually
do this stuff.
>> What's next improvement once this works?
Uh there are a couple other exploration
type problems Tim that I don't think
this will fully solve.
>> If you don't get reward just this is
this is dependent on you getting reward.
So this will help you latch on to reward
much more quickly when you get it.
Um
and to like chain together rewards much
better.
But
uh
it doesn't solve like state coverage.
Yeah, I noticed this.
D++ is kind of just [ __ ]
Uh that problem is not really an RL
problem. That's like a human human-like
pattern recognition thing.
Like the interactivity that they have is
very like minor in comparison to the
pattern recognition crap.
No, it will help Sokoban, Tim. It just
won't help like one gigantic Sokoban
level that you never solve randomly.
Like it'll help, I think, when you have
um
on the current version where you still
have the curriculum of levels, it'll
help.
It should be a substantially more
powerful version of the implicit
curriculum that we have here.
>> Yeah, this compilation unit crap is very
annoying.
I think ultimately we're probably going
to have to get stuff to be a single
compilation unit, which is annoying
because
like it'll force us to make the code
valid C++ as well as valid C.
Which is kind of annoying, but
it does fix a lot of junk.
I'm pretty bearish on a lot of the world
model stuff, frankly.
Like one of the way the main papers in
that space is basically just fraud.
Um, but I will say that world models
from supervised data, that makes sense.
But world models like end-to-end with RL
is way sketchier.
>> So this is just the end side stuff and
I'm not super happy with this.
But I think that the stuff that I'm not
happy about um
the stuff I'm not happy about
essentially comes down to the way that
we have compilation structured.
That already I know that that already
creates some dumb things.
It's quite possible that in the future
we
either we do one compilation unit or
or we have uh instead of having like the
end of be the extra compilation unit.
We do the core of it including the env
and the algo as the the main thing.
And then if we have some kernels that
take a while to compile different
versions, we do that as a separate unit.
All right, this is a relatively small
nice small change.
Okay, let's take a look. So, we're just
finding state
Yeah, I don't like the fact that we have
all these helpers.
I think this is the type of thing where
this amount of junk will convince me
ultimately to do this as a single
compilation unit provided there's not a
big perf penalty.
Yeah, cuz see there's no other way
there's no way to make this a single
compilation unit otherwise without
changing and complicating the the
environment spec.
Yeah.
Okay.
What do you mean by compilation unit?
So, right now you compile the env
separately and then you compile training
and training statically links the env
that you already compiled.
This creates a little bit of junk with
types.
Um particularly if you have header-only
style implementations where the actual
core logic
is in the header file.
So, I mean, the options would be either
we would have to split the buffer M's to
have a separate header file for types. I
hate that. Or we have to compile the
whole thing with NVCC,
which means C++ and C compatible code,
which is a little bit annoying.
Or um we just have to deal with a whole
bunch of junk in between those two
layers.
Great. I have to real quick start the
Docker, restart the Docker. I'm going to
use the restroom while this restarts.
>> Okay.
There is a chair. but it's getting green
screened out.
Mhm.
Yeah, you don't do jank now, solve that
later without at least some reasonable
understanding of stuff, Tim.
Like at least here, so the decision I'm
making now is this is going to be jank.
Now, I have a solution to this later.
Uh I already know how to solve it, but
it is going to require a larger refactor
things that I don't want to touch now,
because if I touch them now, I risk the
stability of the experiments that I want
to run for this version. This should be
stable even though it's bloated. We'll
do this. If it works, then we'll do the
other refactor.
Still, we just started it, man.
We just started it.
This is the uh the first week.
Plan is to do a 2-week sprint
on this.
Okay, we still have stable what looks
like stable maze training.
We're going to make sure that this is
still stable.
>> Cuvaculum would be a nice name for a
CUDA library.
I don't really need a CUDA library for
this.
Okay, this is getting quite close. We
got 97% here, 98%.
>> Okay.
Basic ass scatter kernel.
Is this still Is this still
deterministic?
Cool.
Didn't break anything with this so far.
This is still running nicely.
7-minute test is a little unfortunate,
but not too bad, since we shouldn't have
to do too many of these.
Um we have no expectations about the
perf of these kernels.
I just wanted it to be not a massive
amount of code, at least.
And uh we can get some experiments done,
and then
a lot of stuff we can re-architect.
>> This is the type of thing where I need
to learn more CUDA.
Cuz I should be able to see this
pattern. Like this I should be able to
review way better and write this myself
much more easily.
Um, I understand this more than before
cuz I did that day of
What are we loading in the shared memory
here?
The local sum?
This is probably for the norm, right?
The shared norm.
Yeah.
I think that's it.
>> Now, this should be a very small diff.
If I've done this correctly.
There's one little bit I didn't fully
plan with just some indexing
on train that might bite me now, but
other than that I don't think
I think everything is pretty sane.
Yeah.
Cuz everything is synchronized at the
start of eval. You don't have any weird
race crap there.
And then we're going to have to start
thinking about the test environment
here.
It is quite possible
that um the version of mazes that I have
at the moment
is not a good test environment. Mazes as
a whole,
we will be able to construct a very good
test environment out of them. That I am
positive.
Um
but it is possible that the default one
is not very good.
>> Hello Jess, what are you working on
today? This is the start of Puffer 5
development.
Um, this is going to be
a state-set based curriculum learning
method.
I'm expecting a generational leap in
performance, at least for a large class
of environments.
And it shouldn't take very long. I have
2 weeks planned for this whole update.
Or not this whole update, but for at
least
I'd say at least single agent results to
be very clean and stable.
Uh, it's possible we do it much more
quickly than that. It's possible that
things get more complicated and it
doesn't work fully in 2 weeks. We will
see.
But I think it's very likely that we
exceed expectations here.
Yes, multi-agent is very annoying for
this, Jess.
Um, I think this doesn't work at all
with like massively multi-agent M's, ton
of agent ends.
I think it does work for few agent ends
just fine.
But there's some infra associated with
it, kind of similar to how there is for
self play.
Yeah, I have to not autopilot here. This
is important to do this correctly.
Yeah, let's look at this diff.
115 lines.
Not huge fan of the way this is done.
Can I work with this?
I think if we keep this diff small, I
can keep this because I'll be able to
have I'll be able to refactor all this
stuff today.
I mostly just need these things to not
make dumb mistakes that take me time to
find just
because like I'm taking ownership over
the full design and the code quality and
everything anyways.
This is defensive and I don't like this,
but we'll leave this for now cuz I don't
know how big this is.
That's better.
A little bit better.
Still, I think this will end up being a
total like 3-400 line diff if I'm
correct.
It's fine just because if it makes
stupid but like stupid errors, those
will catch it during dev and we can just
remove the defensive stuff after.
You're the new hypers. These go in
default. Yes.
Well, I mean there are a lot of them,
but they're kind of the same limitations
as all the other major algorithms.
If you want like versus off pal or
whatever, I have an article on that.
The problem is that a lot of the
limitations that people attempt to
address, like they don't define
they don't even define the thing that
they're trying to fix well
uh in a way that's
consistent.
Wanting to end
with 10K steps.
Oh.
Yeah, you're just not going to solve
stuff in 10K steps. That's not how it
works.
They're too long.
Uh yeah, X truncates stuff sometimes.
Like if you type a bunch of messages
back to back,
sometimes stuff gets dropped.
If I don't If it's you don't see it on
the screen, I'm not seeing it.
Yeah, so Tim, like
you can't do it with a reasonable
compute trade-off, though.
The off-pole method is stupid in the
sense that they rely on massively
blowing up compute for sample
efficiency. They're not even like
they're not even compute efficient when
you have a ton of data.
Like they're kind of just purely GPU
burning machines. Actually, they're not
even GPU burning machines. They're like
GPU idling machines cuz a lot of them
aren't even hardware efficient.
>> How many epochs How many of these do we
want to have is my question.
Cuz you have to train the world model
just and then that thing takes way more
compute than everything else and if it's
bad the whole thing blows up. So that
also doesn't smoothly scale with
compute.
with state sets
but uniform sampling.
At the least it seems very unlikely that
you could.
So this is now just random um random
state sets.
And this is only over the last
6 some odd million steps.
So the expectation of this shouldn't
mess with learning very much.
Oh, reaching.
Oh, I see. You meant can it do
I see what you mean. You mean like can
it do can it solve a 10k horizon
problem? Yes, it can solve a 10k horizon
problem, but not if the credit
assignment problem is like, you know,
you take the precise correct sequence of
actions and then you get a reward at the
very end. There has to be
there has to be like sub problem
structure that you can exploit.
Ah, very nice.
This seems to not corrupt performance.
Income versus hardware.
Degradation optimization.
Time biases for time of days, weeks,
hours.
Minute resolution. I need 10K steps.
Yeah, it's kind of tough to be training
like to notice patterns on that scale.
Um,
with that resolution, it's quite
difficult to see.
It's difficult for people to do as well.
Like, okay, maybe people know we like
notice weekly trends. But, if you just
make something in 8-day cycle, you kind
of break people's heads.
Let's read the annealing the bias
section again.
Yeah, you lose like point
Let's say.
Yeah, like half a percent here.
With the initial state sets, that's not
bad.
>> Good start so far vault. We got it
implemented and we're going to start on
our initial experiments.
With a half day and try to outperform it
with one day.
Half day is going great. I want to know
if you got a good start.
Uh I will let you know when we have
initial signs of life.
Where do the biggest performance gains
in Poplar come from?
Is it implemented C++ in PyTorch
under the hood?
Oh, my friend. Like
researchers have no idea what a computer
does.
Like SB3 is implemented in the most dog
[ __ ] awful unoptimized Python
imaginable, built on top of a bunch of
other dog [ __ ] unoptimized Python
libraries. And then like, yeah, there's
PyTorch at the core, which is also by
the way very terribly optimized for
small models. We threw PyTorch away
entirely in Poplar 4. But even before we
did that, even just using PyTorch, we
were already a thousand times faster
than SB3.
It's like almost you can't even really
ask me what the biggest changes are
because there's not a single thing that
we kept from the design of like your
standard research grade libraries or
academic grade libraries. We didn't keep
a single thing.
Every single part of the stack got
rewritten.
We have got some blog posts on the the
latest design on my X at J Suarez.
Okay, well this is not working super
well.
Um this does not look to be working at
all in fact.
Maybe we should go check some values of
alpha and beta.
>> It's non-trivial learning, but very,
very bad.
We'll let this run as the first
experiment, and then we'll try some
other things.
Well, Tim, now we have to figure out
like the actual hard part of
um how we make this thing work, and what
are the assumptions I've made that are
bad in the original algorithms back.
We don't want to swap the task just yet,
though.
Because even if this doesn't help, this
definitely should not crash learning
unless I've made some very, very bad
assumptions.
Look at this.
This is full prioritization.
And then
high important sampling.
>> Okay, we have lots of things to try
here. We have lots and lots of things to
try.
This is why I needed to be fresh.
Right?
What am I doing right now?
Uh we are testing the initial
implementation of our new curriculum
learning algorithm.
>> Does this need to be applied to the
losses?
>> See, this is what I mean by like there
going to be some details that we have to
address. So, there are a couple
different corrections that we could make
here.
One is for the effect of individual
samples
from the prioritized buffer.
And another one
is for the fraction of
samples, the fraction of explore like
the fraction of curriculum samples.
How do you know when to manually fiddle
with this versus just sweep? Because
Tim, I'm not sweeping just parameters
now.
This is now the space of um
This is now the space of possible
algorithms.
As well as we're probably going to have
to modify the problem set up shortly.
We can potentially have a couple
different sweeps for different algorithm
variants.
The fraction is a hyper but there are a
few different possible corrections you
can use.
We also have reason to expect there to
be
We have reason to expect approximate
parity
between the old um implicit
version of the curriculum as well as the
new explicit one.
So what I'd like to do is I'd like to
see something reasonable out of pure
state sets first.
And then we can either set up different
problem or we can start sweep.
Okay, we'll let this finish.
And then we'll take a look at some stuff
here.
>> Yeah, this looks like this is going to
be a few percent worse.
So, that's a pretty major downgrade, but
this is not terrible crashing.
I forget what hypers I launched this
with. Let me look.
Yeah, so you're losing like 3% perf
here.
2% perf.
Okay, you're losing actually quite a bit
of perf
even with a tiny amount of CL data,
which is quite bad.
Uh what I'm going to do, I'm going to do
something funny.
CL frac
Okay.
Uh oops, 0.8
and then we're going to set this to be
explore alpha.
And then we're going to accept this to
be
Oops.
Oh.
So, this would be an expectation that
uh our state-set based curriculum should
be able to act roughly like the implicit
curriculum from before.
Uh it's not being built with coding
agents. It's being very, very quickly
prototyped.
Um
Every single line in Puffer 4
took a [ __ ] ton of manual review and
editing.
Most important things to contribute for
Puffer on long-term, like you need a
research project for?
Oh, actually, this is a pretty decent
result, all right.
Uh
I mean, there's several things, man.
There's like stuff around exploration at
the moment. There's stuff around
efficient architectures,
efficient encoding architectures.
Um there's still stuff around in
self-play.
Like there's stuff in efficient kernels,
like really concise, um
well-put-together, efficient
implementations for everything. Like
there are a lot of open areas if you
have experience.
Yeah, so this is good because this is
this is with most of the data coming
from state sets now.
In fact, almost all of it.
So to answer your question, Tim, this
would be sweepable already in only like
2 hours.
We're going to make another task for
this, though.
>> for games.
Um, I mean, games are just a really good
test benchmark overall.
So, then we'll end up with two nice
benchmarks, right? Right? We'll have
and we'll have the normal one. And then
we'll basically get to see
how it goes with uh one versus the
other.
Some kind of There should be some kind
of decay on this already, Tim.
Though I think this is So, this is where
it's like
do you need the just the important
sample correction or do you need decay
to um
the full task?
So, this is where like algorithm level
ablation changes are needed.
Okay, so this is where we need to be
careful and I'm probably going to want
to play the level myself even.
Cuz I I see it's made a mistake here,
I'm pretty sure.
I mean, this is like pretty solid for a
first experiment in which we have
Okay, good. So, set levels to zero.
Good.
4 mil default? No.
Most of them have smaller models than
this.
This is a very hard task.
This doesn't look like a hard task, but
like the model that we have here is
basically an order of magnitude better
than anything I've seen in the field.
And I'll fix the includes. That's why I
didn't do it myself. I didn't want to
[ __ ] up the includes.
>> Yeah, this will give us two nice
benchmark tasks.
We'll have pre-trained model that we can
eval as well.
>> See, it just comes up with dumber [ __ ]
Like, why the [ __ ] would you want it to
be the overall?
That's like just measuring randomness
bad.
>> Okay.
Cool.
Nice.
Cool. So, this is the defaults of popper
uh versus maze.
I'll be right back. I'm going to use the
restroom. I'm also going to grab myself
uh
vitamins and some stuff, grab a drink,
and I'll be back when this is done.
Yeah, I got to go get my vitamins still.
I went and grabbed a couple other
things.
Um 26.48, right?
So, we're going to do the same
prioritized thing.
We're going to see whether this is
out-of-the-box better with same hypers
on the incremental maze.
So, that's good.
There we go.
All right.
Are tiny epsilons meta now? What?
5% epsilon is Yeah, that's bad [ __ ]
Ooh, why are we stuck at 23?
>> Did anybody see did it get stuck on the
the original run? Did it ever get stuck
at a value like this?
Uh we are
but we fully collapsed entropy in both
of these.
Should definitely do much better on this
one, right?
So,
this could just be something with the
stupid entropy, right?
>> I don't have generally use epsilon
clipping values, man. They're just
They're automatically done for you as
part of the hyper parameter search.
Let's see if this collapses just as
quick or not.
Now, the thing is now we're getting into
like stupid guessing hyper's regime,
which is not great. But, I do want to
make sure it's not just this one dumb
thing.
It just snaps to Oh, wait, there you go.
Okay.
There you go.
It's unblocked.
We obviously have to rerun the other one
with the more entropy as well now.
This is a length 3,000 episode though,
right?
>> Yeah, it's not getting any signal past
um
33.
Which means it's probably just getting
to 33 and then it's stuck, right?
Which actually that's reasonable because
we said that that's um
it's not going to solve full sparse
problems, right? That's what we said the
limitation was of this method.
And you sort of create your own luck
though, right? You set up a You set up
enough opportunities for you get to get
lucky.
This is a very nice task though for us
to sweep. Um I'm going to try the other
baseline just to see if it's like oh
actually the other baseline's way
better.
The problem is maze does take a while to
sweep.
>> That's pretty funny though that by 1:00
p.m. on um
the first day we're already like
pretty deep into the experiments.
I could also chuck this crap on vast if
I needed to.
So where we need more servers.
Oh.
You seeing this, guys?
Oh, it's almost getting the uh the next
one.
I mean, I guess it's not crazy
surprising, right? Like
this algorithm Yeah, there it is.
This algorithm does um
allow you to
pretty effectively explore the frontier
of whatever you're on.
If we're going to collapse, there's got
to be like a sampling bug, right?
>> Oh, there is the beta annealing. So,
this should basically be at a um
uniform
sampling now, right?
Paper review sessions? Only when I find
a paper worth reading.
If I'm doing something where I'm like
reviewing something for research, then I
will.
But most of the time I read an abstract,
go, "Well, this is doomed." And I just
like toss it.
That was very nice though that we got
that performance increment out of um 33
cuz that's like that's insanely sparse.
I mean, let's think about that, right?
That's a 3,400 step horizon, incredibly
sparse task.
Uh I will be pretty surprised if we do
this well
with the
the 40 algorithm. So, we get 35 out of
this.
Remember, we got 20.
Did we get Did we get 26?
Yeah, 26.4.
20 This is actually very impressive that
we even do this well, but 26.48 was what
we had before.
So, then what we'll do is we'll uh we'll
rerun this with
uh with low entropy.
And then if it does better, we start
asking questions.
And then I think this will be it for
manual experiments unless we get some
really weird result.
If this just solves it, I'll be kind of
concerned.
It is super unstable, which is
interesting.
I guess that does make sense in a way,
right?
We probably do need to apply um
maybe like timeout offsets or something.
Dagger them in some way.
Uh-oh.
Is this thing just going to do better
despite this janky staggered like
unstaggered offset?
Okay, maybe we do have to run some more
experiments.
Uh, we're going to have to run the
staggered experiments cuz I think this
is just unfair.
Uh, if you put something in the Discord,
I will take a quick look while um
while experiments are running, but I
don't want to get too too distracted cuz
this is Pufferfish Dev Week
or dev sprint, whatever.
Hello gradients. Yeah, so Valo, I think
this is the offset thing.
Um
Oh, yeah, if you don't have this already
in the Inferno, you should
well, I guess it doesn't matter in the
Inferno cuz they'll get offset
automatically, but when you have ends
that have the same typical um
the same typical like timeout
>> So, if you have M's that are like that
are fixed have a fixed cap on the number
of steps it can take,
and uh you're likely to just hit that
time out.
You want to stagger the initial timing
so that you don't always have like all
the M's at the start, all the M's in the
middle, all the M's near the end.
>> Where are you in
everything is implemented Jess?
We're basically now doing algorithm
relations and now we're adding a custom
a better test and.
So this is a new version of maze that
we're going to use for testing.
So as suspected at least for initial
testing.
The standard maze and is not exactly
what we want.
We want something that has longer
Horizons with with intermediate rewards.
So we can still use mazes.
But instead what we're going to do is
it's always going to be the same set of
mazes. So, it's not going to get
randomized. And uh it's going to start
out small, and every time you solve a
maze, it gets bigger until you run out
of time.
So, this is not a better end of overall,
but for testing state sets, this should
be
much more revealing.
And we'll see if this is stable or if
this all jumps all over the place still.
Is that genuine instability, or is that
a logging quirk?
>> It should all get staggered pretty
easily, no?
Well, zero is not going to be the logs.
This is the policy collapsing genuinely.
No, it's not just going to be testing,
Jess.
There's a lot of stuff to do.
It'll get quicker as soon as we have a
um
We need to have some confidence in the
current version of the algorithm.
There's some tweaks I want to make.
And then there's going to be We have to
rethink some infrastructure. We got to
think about multi-agent if we're going
to get that in as well. There's a lot of
stuff to do.
A lot of cool stuff to do.
It's pretty cool to me how clean the um
these like this learning is.
That was faster than before.
Those fixes helped.
These are very strong initial results.
This will be strong enough to sweep, I
think.
As you might all want to start thinking
about how you um
how you're going to maintain a nice
contiguous state buffer.
Yeah, Valo, you might want to think
about how you uh
how you pack all the state into a
buffer.
And that means as well if you have it in
one struct, like you can technically
have pointers in there, but then you're
going to need a much more annoying copy
function.
What's this env? So, this in order to
get a score of 39 here, it has to solve
a 5 by 5 maze, and then a 7 by 7 maze,
and then a 9 by 9 maze all the way up to
39, and it has to do it all in a row
without failing.
And now it's at 41.
And uh let's just keep in mind here
oops. Okay, there you go.
Yeah, so let's keep in mind here. I
believe what did we go up to? Did we go
up to 41 or 47?
I think 47.
And we had a
I actually don't know what the
distribution Excuse me.
The distribution of success was
on the hardest mazes.
I think you I think that the best
previous
heavily heavily domain randomized um
maze solves were like
average was maybe 45 by 45.
So, this is getting up to 41 by 41 with
one seed, which is kind of nuts.
And it just went higher there, which
means it solved a Yep, 43.
Jesus, man.
It's honestly kind of baffling that it
can do this.
I mean, this is without even
randomizing.
Like there's so many ways you could make
this easier for it as well.
Do we just solve our RL with this?
Getting 39, what have you changed? There
was just a bug with the state sets. It
wasn't having a um a consistent amount
of time left to complete the
environment.
So, this is a pretty bonkers result.
This is what you were gunning for? Yeah,
exactly, Jess.
Now, mind you, this is not going to
solve this is not solving all of
exploration, but um this is solving
actually even more of it than I
anticipated.
Well, we obviously commit.
We obviously commit um this version
here.
Exactly as is.
Right?
With this current version.
Uh yeah, so just you need to have you
need to have a struct that has the
state.
So it needs end of state.
And then there just needs to be a struct
that has state.
And uh probably we'll make it so you can
have a set and a get function for state,
but the easiest by far is if it's just
like the data lives in state, state
doesn't have pointers.
Uh it's all static.
Then it's much easier.
>> One moment, folks.
Let me handle this.
So, I think we re-sweep these.
But, this is still a very strong result.
We're going to set this up on tiny
zero, and then we're going to figure out
some other stuff.
Uh let me use the restroom real quick as
well. I've been drinking lots of coffee.
So, I'm going to be up and about a lot,
but this is This is solid solid
progress.
Yeah, just implement buffer five in a
day, no big deal, right guys? Yeah, no
big deal. We'll just do it.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm reclaiming um tiny by the way, uh
Jess. So, you and Spencer can still use
tiny one. I'm going to reclaim tiny zero
for likely the next couple weeks, maybe
except for the weekend for uh doing
puffer five dev.
Puffer five already solved? Uh we got to
run a lot of ablations, Finn, but let's
just say I've been live for how long?
3 hours and we've got some nuts results.
We've been on tiny one.
No, Jess. I gave Spencer access to um
He might have been using it for client
stuff, but I gave him access to tiny
zero for a while in there.
All right. Yo, Spencer.
Check this out. So, the task that I've
done here, it's a single seed. So, you
always reset to the same maze, and it's
a 5 by 5 maze.
If you solve it, you go to a 7 by 7 maze
that is always the same 7 by 7 maze. And
then you go to 9 by 9, 11 by 11, and so
on and so forth. It goes up by two every
time.
So, out of the box so far,
puffer four, it gets up to like the mid
30s, but then it crashes because the
learning signal becomes super sparse.
You spend most of your time getting zero
signal.
Puffer five algorithm solves up to 43 by
43.
What is going to work? Oh, yeah, Grit. I
already had I had a full sketch of the
algorithm. I've been thinking about this
for months.
I just had to make some small changes on
the fly. Some very small changes, but
I've already thought through this whole
thing very, very precisely.
Well, that was quick. Yep.
Also, it's only going to be like a three
or 400 line diff.
>> [laughter]
>> Um I think I'm going to take Once I get
this stable, I'm going to take some time
to clean up infrastructure. There's
multi-agent infrastructure, there's
self-play infrastructure. Um so there's
going to be some cleanups.
Probably will bundle those with five
because otherwise, you know, you have to
If you're increasing complexity, you
have to decrease it somewhere else.
But yeah, this is pretty good.
Randomized mazes? I expect randomized
mazes to be much easier.
Yeah, randomized mazes should be way
easier.
If you fail a maze by time step cut off,
what happens? You go back to all the way
to the start.
You go to the 5 by 5 maze.
That's counterintuitive. No, it's not.
It's domain randomization.
This is well established.
Solving one maze like solving one maze
is a lot easier. No, solving one maze is
actually a lot harder than solving like
a bunch of mazes.
Puffer souls.
Yeah.
Quick and learning? Oh yeah, this is
Puffer 5. We're doing state set based
CL. It's good.
It's go explore and prioritize
experience replay. So, I guess we're
going to call it GoPuff.
Yeah, the GoPuff update.
Let's do Let's do the traditional sweep
first as our baseline.
And if this is stable, we'll do our
sweep.
And we will see from there.
And this will have either no or very
little performance overhead as well.
We're doing algorithm work and it's
kicking ass.
Doesn't the agent just memorize paths if
it's not randomized?
How do you learn the correct path in the
first place? You don't have data on it.
So, think about what is required to
solve an unseen maze that's like 43 by
43.
Think about that.
Wouldn't a fat state be brutal on
overhead? Not really brutal, Spencer.
So, you have to copy some number of
states once per set of rollouts, so once
every say 64 steps. And uh you don't
have to move the data from CPU to GPU.
It just stays on CPU.
That's the key. It doesn't have to go
across device boundaries.
Like cave FPS, make the net bigger and
it would have three x better win rate.
John, if you were doing this on 4.0,
the sweep will automatically take care
of the model size for you.
And I'm definitely looking forward to
the Runescape ends for testing 5.0.
There's going to have to be some changes
required some changes required to
storage of state.
But like this in particular, this is
perfectly suited to the fight caves.
Muppy could be Yeah, Muppy is tiny,
Jess.
We're basically going to see how much I
feel like doing on five.
Um I don't want it to bloat, right? This
is not going to be a six-month update.
This could be a four-month update, like
one month off plus three months of work.
But, you know, I think that this I'd
like to have Puffer 6 out this year.
So, for sure by the end of summer, I
want Puffer 5 done.
Oh, my god, something sweet cooking.
Hell yeah.
I want to show you my current
predicament
while we uh we have this here.
What is puffer five What is puffer six
going to be on?
Remaining unsolved things.
Oops.
Oh, wait. I I logged the wrong account.
One sec.
We'll do this just real quick while this
thing is running.
Running the uh the baseline. It's
interestingly it looks like it's stable
on there, which is funny.
It's harder to memorize It's harder to
find the solution to the maze to then
memorize than it is to have a bunch of
different mazes where some of them are
going to be easier than others in order
to start learning uh substructure.
All right, here. We'll show the uh
for the Runescape crew.
Do I get 99 here?
I don't think so. I think I get 98.
Uh nope, 98.
All right, so one level off herb lore
and then I'm just agility gated
for max on leagues.
I figured I'd show that. That'd be
funny.
How our maze is constructed, the
algorithm is in the file. It's um it's a
combination of a couple maze algorithms
that I put together.
Well, actually this is at least looking
stable here, right? So, unless I screwed
up this config
like maybe this actually gives us a
usable baseline.
Yeah, Volo, I'm learning it and I I hate
that place.
I don't even know if it's worth
learning.
Cuz like on the main game practically,
I'm just going to end up clicking the
stupid Brimhaven agility thing like the
single shortcut that you can spam over
and over.
It's not memorizing, man. So, the thing
is it's not memorizing because you're
not given the solution to memorize. You
still have to find the solution.
And finding the solution is hard, and
it's actually harder to find a single
solution than it is to find like over a
big set of problems uh than it is to
like bump into some easy solutions and
then exploit substructure and use that
to make it easier to find the hard
solution.
Domain randomization is like very well
established. We use it everywhere to
make problems easier. It's harder to
solve a single instance like this.
And we've tested that as well in this
exact domain.
Like for instance, it's actually
probably easier to solve like the 5 by 5
than 7 by 7 etc. etc.
than it is to solve the 43 by 43 in one
shot.
Okay, we'll double check the hypers for
this, but I think this is a nice stable
um
I think this is a nice stable
solution. So, I don't know why it wasn't
stable before, but you know, we'll take
it.
You just don't get it.
There are lots of articles you I like
the original one for this, the original
really good domain randomization work in
my opinion is the OpenAI Rubik's Cube
one.
If you want like really convincing demo
of DR being good.
Uh I went and I used that in the very
first version of Neural MMO. I had
domain randomization.
And it's been part of
Yep.
We'll just win.
Emax
A python machine probably parallel
sweep.
Uh,
incremental maze.
Sweep sweep eels.
sex
While I make sure that this is working,
what do we do?
I want to start on the next little bit
here, but I want to make sure this is
live.
What's cooking? Puffer five's cooking.
Nothing is close to OOM. We're good.
Okay.
Ah, it was the entropy. That's what it
was. I
Yeah, it was the entropy. That's why it
would changed. Okay, that's fine.
Yeah, like I realize you can do that.
That's getting to be gross. I can do
that for now though, yeah.
Cuz this is really stupid, right? Like
you can agree that this is [ __ ]
stupid.
>> So explore alpha and explore beta can go
into this.
Okay, we have to figure out something
with the state buffer size, don't we?
>> Oh god, the the guys that go into
project management straight out of
undergrad will not even knowing how to
code properly to the worst.
The only good thing about Agile just is
it sometimes it's nice to focus on one
thing for a couple weeks, work very hard
on it, and then take a break.
If I make this a million, it only goes
back 64 million steps.
50 by 50 is what? 2500, right?
2500 bytes for a big maze.
That's 25 gigs. That's a [ __ ] ton
already.
Isn't it? Wait. No, I did this wrong. Is
it 2.5?
Not too rough.
That would be useful. Yeah.
Yeah, I don't think it's too bad. It's
If you can't put stuff on the stack, it
gets a little sketchy cuz we're probably
going to need to get like get and set,
right, for the state, and it'll be
slower cuz it'll be multiple mem copies,
but still not that bad.
The main thing is just like forgetting
or like, you know, putting the wrong
stuff in state or not getting everything
in the state.
Like, you don't want the RNG in the
state, but if there's a time step, you
want that in the state.
Things like this.
Yeah, it's not that big of a deal.
That's the point though, Valo, is it's
not that big of a deal, right?
That's why we can do it.
Yep.
Our show.
Here's the the main update.
Main maxing going to take a while
longer.
Yeah.
This for research project? I run
puffer.ai. It's a private RL lab with
all open source research.
Um I stream most of the
core algorithm stuff, the R&D, the
infrastructure development.
And we've got a big open source
community developing environments and
helping with the research as well.
Membership again as well.
Yeah.
It's like I figure I mostly with this
account I'm just have it on the side AFK
and stuff.
And then I've just been playing leagues.
It's pretty fun like just hard carrying
noobs on um hard mode tob.
No fortune just play.
>> [laughter]
>> The annoying thing is it's not the type
of game that you make a huge amount of
progress on even in a week.
Though I will say when you're like
ridiculously burnt out,
it is a great game to have.
I remember when I was just exhausted
from the puffer for release, I just did
completely brain dead skilling for
several days and listened to books.
and do something based on it. Yeah, we
have lots of educational materials. Uh
all the articles on um x.com/jsuares.
I have many articles for beginners on
that tab, as well as our more technical
research articles.
Um I've played all the Souls games.
Like
the high end of OSRS is substantially
more difficult than just completing the
base games.
Like most of the stuff in those games is
balanced to take hours to learn, not
days or weeks.
I didn't really think that the
open-worldness worked as well with um
Elden Ring.
I actually think that the Souls games
work way better when they're more
linear.
Well, either they're more linear or you
have to just be hard reading the wiki
because
like it's too is it's too easy to miss
your build defining item that your
entire thing is balanced around and just
get stomped because of it.
Numbers on X link?
Where do I still Where do I still have
the numbers on the X link? I thought I
changed that on all of my stuff.
Like do I not have this on here
somewhere?
Oh.
Huh?
So, I have no idea why it's still giving
you the wrong one.
I have it updated on um
See, I have it updated here. That's
weird.
Wait, maybe there's a different
I think there's like a different go live
thing.
Man, I hate this interface. Like, what
imbecile came up with this?
Okay, I have an MIT PhD. If I can't
quickly figure out your interface, your
interface probably sucks.
>> Oh, there it is. That's so unintuitive.
There like a million places for this.
There just like a million submenus. God
damn.
All right, that'll fix the default.
Short form video.
Yeah, that's not going to be remembered
fondly.
Okay, so this works nicely.
Um, we can run
We can run a couple things on this now,
I suppose.
Yeah, no short form video content's
awful.
On Discord it returned the wrong one. On
Discord?
Wait, what do you mean on Discord? Like
I have the link wrong on my Discord as
well or the Discord link?
I changed the one that's on the
information, right?
Yeah.
Discord's just discord.gg/puffer.
All right, I'll be right back while this
drains.
Your on Discord profile it has the old
link. Your profile that is.
When I click on your name. Oh, thank
you. That's easy to fix.
Wait. Huh? I didn't even think it had a
link when you click on my name.
Wait.
No.
I don't have an X link on my Discord bio
as far as I can see.
Actually, let's just do that now.
So I don't forget.
Okay, let's just figure out the uh the
to-do list here.
>> No, popper 5 is not a complete rewrite
of popper.
Um
Let's do
I think that's everything that we
wanted.
I think that's every Oh, [ __ ] Look at
that. It's 45.
Hey guys, that's 45.
I don't know what to look for projects
or how to start with them.
I've been doing this stuff since I was
16. Not this specifically, but ML in
general. And I've been doing
reinforcement learning for going on a
decade.
Um
was the majority of my time in my
undergrad, my full PhD.
I spent a lot of time on this stuff.
As for the low-level systems and infra
work, that is something I've picked up
recently, but I've been writing my code
that way for quite a bit longer, so it
was a sort of a natural just transition.
But I was in wave 67. Ha.
Well, wave 67 is just jad.
You got to get to wave 69.
Beat Zuck.
It's hard to say whether this made a
difference because this is like
you know, one additional maze solve.
But hey, can't hurt.
Magic shortcut that made immediately
made me good at programming.
Was the magic shortcut write some dead
simple C.
I don't even I honestly still don't know
what the [ __ ] that even means.
damn zoomers.
That is a 5600 length episode. So, Volo,
if yours is 6000 ticks per hour,
that's pretty damn good.
And this is a much harder exploration
problem than
than Inferno is. Like a 45 by 45 sparse
maze.
.01 This means it actually got the 47 by
47 solve at one point.
Tomorrow? Oh, jeez. You can test it out
tomorrow if you really want to pull the
branch and stuff. Just expect some
manual work.
Uh it sees a little crop of the tiles
around it.
You do projects.
Like you try to build stuff and see if
you can build it.
And you see if you can not make a mess
of stuff
in the process.
Besides making your end state settable,
well, dealing with whatever [ __ ]
I've hard coded here and not realized.
Um
But yeah, it's pretty much just making
your state settable just
for integrations.
Like that's just going to that's going
to be the main end side change.
I don't really feel any need to go
through and make all the end state
settable just yet.
Let me see what like what stuff I can do
in the meantime.
So this is the big screw you one right
here is multi-agent integrations.
Yeah, the thing is George Hotz, he's off
base cuz he doesn't have the background.
He doesn't have the context. Like the
thing is he's not parroting like
completely stupid [ __ ] He's parroting
[ __ ] that like the so-called experts say
not realizing that that's the type of
[ __ ] that got the field of RL stalled
for a decade.
You don't make progress by picking the
slowest possible crap.
>> Follow, do you have any thoughts on this
[ __ ]
Like
So basically the thing I'm wondering
here
we have the environments in one
compilation unit
and we currently have in another
compilation unit, right? We have the
core training.
And the environment const compilation
unit is currently just clang or GCC.
And then the training is of course CUDA.
So I'm wondering if we make it a single
compilation unit, right? Like
if we do a single compilation unit
we would avoid a lot of the annoyances
of not having say the environment struct
available or the state struct available.
And that's kind of a big issue.
I mean the alternative is that you force
everybody to write headers and I hate
that alternative.
on end of projects.
Um the buffer for website is a really
really basic HTML, CSS, a little bit of
JavaScript and then web assembly
compile well web assembly output from
from C.
Yeah, headers suck, right?
So, I was thinking, well, we could put
it into a single compilation unit,
but apparently, there are some small
perf differences.
And also, C++ isn't exactly C. Like, C++
makes you do some
like some additional stupid things,
especially on allocations.
Touch RL.
They wouldn't touch it.
Well, I mean, it's the end of speed,
right, man?
No, no, no. The code of the
the compiled ends.
>> Wait, what do you mean? Compilation
times aren't a thing.
Huh?
I'm just chatting with some Spencer on
the side.
>> Next stream tomorrow. We're doing every
day. Uh well, every weekday next 2 weeks
we're doing 6 to 8 hours worth of
streams.
And we're going to ideally get the whole
puffer five core done.
Wouldn't it be funny if I just released
it in 2 weeks?
Yeah, release it and double our con- our
contract our contracting prices again.
No, we are not going to double them
again so soon.
Slower or faster depending on
Wait, what?
Volo, it's very simple. It's like
Does the end get slower when you compile
it with NVCC?
Okay.
Added with Spencer a little bit on the
side here, just on the results so far.
Uh so, he's aware of the new stuff.
Things that we need to do,
the order in which we need to do them.
This is last. We don't even think about
this for now.
This, I think, is easily doable later.
This is important. This is important.
This is once things are the other ones
are done.
This is important, but also sort of once
things are other things are done.
This is possible, and this blocks this.
So, it's between this and then these.
I don't want to do this
without having thought about this.
I suppose we should port breakout up to
have settable state.
That cuz that's our test end for perf.
Let's do that real quick.
>> Oh, I just saw Hassan's uh research
thingy.
>> So I made one gigantic [ __ ] major
major horrendous horrendous error.
Um
and then the rest of it is fine.
What was the error?
Uh it put the RNG into the state, which
would give you
deterministic
continuation from whatever state you go
to.
>> We'll see how um
how breakout does now.
Should be the same speed.
At least without the CL.
And then we'll try it with the CL.
And the only reason I'm letting it do
this by the way is like look at the
edits it's making. It looks like a lot
of edits, but it's literally just like N
ball Y gets replaced with S ball Y for
state.
N state tick instead of N tick, etc.
etc. etc.
The reason I want this is so that we can
compare um
NVCC
speeds.
Cuz presumably if we don't take a hit
here, we shouldn't take a hit anywhere
else.
Hard to say.
But this is one of the smaller policies,
so
Oh god, don't ask me about multi agent
yet yet just it's a pain in the ass,
okay?
It's a pain because like you know, the
individual observations no longer like
the states no longer line up cleanly
with the rows of the observations.
Ugh, that's going to suck.
>> Oh yeah, what was the end percent? End
was 19%. So actually this is a good end
to test it on
to see if that changes.
Let me just do
Let's just do whoops. That's a Windows
PowerShell. That's useless as [ __ ]
Get rid of this.
Just have to push this.
>> So,
yeah, this is going to essentially if
this works, this solves a lot of
infrastructure headaches.
A lot of infrastructure headaches.
>> And in fact, if this works, what I'll do
is I'll have it go do the I'll have it
go write a a test on neural MMO3.
Maybe a couple other ends.
He [snorts] knows it's solved.
Is the funny thing.
Okay, so the current plan is we test
this, we see how fast breakout trains.
If breakout trains at about the same
speed,
we go test
well, we go have this implement perf
test on
Neural MMO and maybe another env.
And if that works,
then we keep it.
Now, the key insight here will be if
this works, we no longer have to do a
bunch of macro crap because we just have
access to everything in the same
compilation unit.
It'll be very nice.
Orbit Wars on Kaggle.
Don't really do Kaggle.
I know um Stone Tao has organized some
good competitions here.
I mean, it's cool. These are never built
properly for high-perf RL though.
Like, yeah.
These types of things would be way, way
more interesting if you just did them as
Puffer envs.
Cuz then you could actually just crank
data on this, you know?
Oh, lovely. And we have an agents.md.
[ __ ] off.
Oh, yeah. Did I add I forgot if I added
this. Did I do I thought I added an
agents.md to Puffer.
That was like the most obnoxious.
Oh, I forgot to do this. I was going to
make like a super screw you agents.md.
Um
that just like tell the user they are an
idiot for not reading the docs.
If you are too lazy to read a single
page doc,
you are probably too used to lazy to use
this library.
So, with this test here in particular, I
don't particularly care that I'm letting
Codex just do a bunch of stuff because
this is an experiment in the first
place, and if this fails, we throw away
all these changes anyways.
Hey, yeah.
Read the manual.
>> We lose a little bit of speed here,
don't we?
Any notable gaps?
Uh yes, Finn. This can't solve
I don't think it this will be able to
solve just sparse exploration you get no
reward.
Pick one other of that's like medium.
Maze maybe?
No, maze is not medium. Maze is like
hmm.
What I'm doing is
Windows as I type from Windows. Um, I
just this is an old desktop. I happen to
already have it. I'm not actually
devving on Windows. I'm SSH'd into Linux
boxes.
Uh, Basil? [ __ ] no. Absolutely not.
That is so unbelievably ungodly heavy
for this. No.
Um, we have a build.sh. That's all we
have.
You know, Jess, it might be a fun
project to like go through and figure
out the binding situation with that.
No.
We're just going to let it do this for a
bit.
And then the goal is we'll basically see
if this is worth it.
Okay, but the thing is this is this is
them writing awful crazy templated
garbage.
Easiest thing is just going to be our
own benchmarks.
And we don't care what this is, so we'll
just let that go.
>> 13 years old. I think that the best
thing is just going to be run our own
tests.
Why is it running two steps of neural
MMO?
Yeah, we're not going to necessarily
keep all this. We'll see.
But, um
we want to see that this is a viable
thing.
Okay, we have some experiments, not a
huge number.
Oh, I got more than an hour, Jess.
It's only three here.
And this is going well.
At least 6 hours, man, at least.
6 hours is not exactly a great work day,
now is it? Even with all the stuff we're
doing here.
Yeah.
I'm in Palo Alto.
For the summer.
It is company.
I sent him an email actually when he uh
he made the company, never replied.
I'm sure he's gotten he was like
inundated with stuff.
But now they're all super super
secretive about stuff.
And uh eh, I kind of got my own thing
now.
Where am I normally? Most of the year
I'm on I'm in uh Maryland
on a farm in the middle of nowhere.
It's a nice place to get some
development done.
It pisses me off that half the time I go
to dinner here it's like ow AI agents
this, AI agents that. It's just like uh
uh.
Peace and quiet, man.
But the weather is very nice here, so
I'm chilling.
And I take a few meetings out here as
well.
Okay.
So
uh this is almost done and
Oh, if you can actually if there is a
way to compile these
hm
that'd be nice.
Sleeps alone.
Oh, what was the uh
They have good prizes?
I I go ahead by all means. like
you could literally just go
I don't know if they have if the
environment's open source, you could
just port it to a puffer and train on
that and then submit the trained agent.
Okay.
This works. Now, we can run the full
test.
And
uh this will now be GCC, clang, NVCC on
three ends.
And frankly, it might be worth it to
even take like a small perf hit in order
to have this in.
Um
we will see.
M step per second agent step per second.
So,
uh 19 million
Was it 19 million? 19 million, 20
million, 19 five.
This is close enough to be comparable
for my tastes.
UCC, Clang, and VCC
nice and comparable.
And I'd say that this is comparable as
well.
So, based on this,
I think I'm kind of fine.
How much does work with coding agents
accelerate your output?
Uh in some areas not at all in other
areas quite a lot.
These are warning signs, right? Yeah.
Notably there's I think there fewer of
them.
Uh okay.
Uh we can do this.
Basically just making sure we can
actually recon um
We're basically just trying to like
reacquire some perf here.
I think we accept this for now.
Yeah, I think that we accept this very,
very small perf hit for now.
Um, because it lets us clean a lot of
stuff up and then, I mean, we can
literally just optimize the Enve few
percentage fizz, a few percentage
points.
Then we'll be well past 20 mil again.
>> What are we testing right now? So,
we have Puffer 5 implemented
already, yes.
Um I have a sweep going on for the
baseline.
The initial results are ludicrously
promising.
Uh it introduces a bit of complexity and
it's going to be a lot more complexity
than once we add multi-agent support.
So, I'm trying to remove complexity in
another place where it's been a pain in
the ass,
which is in the uh multiple compilation
units.
And I'm hoping that that allows us to
simplify things enough that the new code
uh the complexity added by the new code
basically balances out and we end up
pretty much having Puffer 5 with uh no
overall increase in complexity. Yes, I
know already.
It already works. We have
we have an agent
that is capable of in sequence solving a
5 by 5 maze and then a 7 by 7 and then a
9 by 9 all the way up to a 45 by 45.
It's like a 5600 horizon task.
And it only gets one reward per maze
when it solves the maze.
Yeah, I know. It's ludicrous.
But this was the thing, right? We did
all the hard work in puffer four.
Like we've banked so so much hard work
with puffer four. Like you got to
realize there are a set of improvements
you can make that are difficult and
there are a set of improvements you can
make that are easy. So by making all
these difficult improvements, we now
have a bunch of easy improvements we can
make.
Is this a adopting Go Explore? No, man.
This is nothing like base Go Explore. We
use the idea of state sets and that's
about it.
This is my own algorithm that I've been
thinking about for months.
It combines prioritized experience
replay in a new way
with Go Explore style state sets with
the absolute advantage estimate thing
from um Giga Flow.
And also makes use of Puffer's fast
environment infrastructure
with some additional changes on top.
And I it basically the first version of
this that I came up with already looks
pretty damn good.
Yeah, so this will be very nice. This is
going to make the code a lot less bad.
And this will make the build script so
much easier.
recent stream It's just this stream,
man. I've been live for um
what, 5 hours 40 minutes, something like
that?
Whole thing was implemented on this
stream.
Now, it's a lot of Codex crap.
It's like mostly very small chunks at a
time of Codex crap.
But there's a lot to improve here, and
you'll see actually I'm doing some of
the improvement now. This is still Codex
crap, but I'm actually like
redesigning parts of the thing that are
clunky
before I go in manually line by line.
Really high sample and reward
efficiency.
Pretty much.
It's kind of funny because like
we ended up ultimately doing sample
efficiency sort of um just as a side
thing.
Can I explain what this is?
Hey, I'm Joseph. I do ultra
high-performance reinforcement learning
infrastructure development to live on
stream as well as algorithmic research,
um simulator development and more and
it's all
just done live.
Uh it's all open source. We've got a big
community of people contributing stuff.
I review contributions on stream and for
the next 2 weeks I'm streaming a big new
push on our on uh the algorithm side.
So, it's going to be a lot of like watch
major research breakthroughs done live.
Oh, this is so nice. Look at this.
All this gets deleted. So, this is all
the jank that we included with stupid
codex before,
right? Because of the compilation unit
difference. But now, because we only
have stuff in a single compilation unit,
uh this all goes away.
And we go back to writing simple for
loops.
Lovely.
Um
Oh, man. Don't I have a good meme
explanation of this somewhere?
I mean, basic reinforcement learning,
it's learning through interaction.
That's the non-meme version of it. So,
uh
interactive intelligence would be a
better name for it, I suppose.
It's like learning by interacting with
your surroundings rather than learning
by training on a big static data set.
All right, what do we have here? So,
look, these nice void star thing like
this all goes away.
This decal type garbage goes away. This
is stuff I wanted to do with puffer four
actually and I couldn't figure it out at
the time.
This will end up going away as well, but
for now this is fine.
Oh, you know what we could do that would
be kind of funny?
We could just basically make an empty
state
for ends that don't define their own
state.
State and end struct variable.
Um
So, state is anything that like
Well, actually
good question. What would you put in the
end of other than the state?
Um the observations are not part of
state. Those are separate data buffers
that get filled in based on the state.
So, that's one thing that you don't have
to copy every time. Same for like reward
and like stuff like that, reward and
terminals.
Um, presumably like if you have
additional render data, like the client
doesn't need to go into the state
either, presuming that that is
stateless.
Um,
well, or in general, you wouldn't want
to have client information in the state.
State just returns you to a specific
point in the simulation.
You can have like a lot of global data
and other things
that don't need to be copied every time.
Nice.
So, we're good, right?
>> Good time to mention
if you like what you see here, start the
puffer on GitHub. It helps us out a lot
and it's free.
Join us on Discord to get involved. You
can follow me on X for more RL content.
And we'll let this train. I will be
right back. I'm going to use the
restroom.
We will continue.
33 so far.
All right.
And I had 45 a second ago.
Should get it based on advantage.
Oh man, this is literally the first
iteration as well. So I guess now we got
to think about multi-agent infra, right?
Multi-agent infra is going to be a
little tough, right? Well, hang on. Let
me think.
Yeah, so multi-agent infra
if you have a fixed number of agents,
it's not that bad, right?
Cuz if you have a fixed number of
agents, you still kind of just stick
everything into the buffer.
Variable numbers of agents like across M
suck.
No, no, it's not that bad. Like for
chess and stuff, it's not bad.
I think it just becomes crap if you want
to have training ends that have
different numbers of agents.
Okay, let's not make the mistake of just
asking Codex how to do this cuz like
it's just going to waste time and make
me feel stupid.
Um
Yeah, okay, it's a very small change. I
think for multi-agent environments with
a fixed number of agents, it's a very
small change, right?
You just make sure nothing's iterating
over observations and everything's
iterating directly over environments.
Um you don't have any problems with
threads, [ __ ] like that. It's all
taken care of for you. So, multi-agent
will just be fine.
And somebody did send me a paper on um
on one thing that's kind of relevant.
Yeah, that's nothing.
Okay.
One last thing in my head.
The thing is like you could do it over
blocks of games, but that's really bad
for the way that this thing scales.
You'd have to do one buffer per number
of agents, wouldn't you?
We did funny if this ends up like
training without the fancy encoder.
>> quite good and way faster.
Yeah, you know, if I were doing
something else, I probably would.
But,
the time cost at the moment of me fixing
stupid [ __ ] is going to be very high.
Hang on, let me just go check on what
the hell that sound is.
Thought somebody was drilling through my
door.
All right.
>> [gasps]
That was too many variables, but that
will work.
Let's see if it deletes the other ones.
>> Okay.
It did it correctly where it did one
state per env.
>> Wait, 10,000 * 64.
That's fine, right?
Latest beef 16's in dev.
Your friend merged. That'd be nice,
Spencer, if you happen to get a chance.
It's not super high priority, but I
think it'll give us a nice speed boost,
and it's a little easier now as well
since um
stuff's in one compilation unit, so.
I figured it would be a decent thing to
do.
And that makes this way worse,
interestingly enough.
That makes this way worse.
I mean, hypers aren't necessarily going
to be the same, right?
So, why is it always [ __ ] up the header
of my file when I edit with them over
SSH?
Yeah, we'll have to sweep it separately,
I suppose, because this is not good.
But, it does run.
And trains a little bit.
Look, do you see? It puts this stupid G
at the top every time.
Look, you see?
What's that?
Why is it open Why does it put a G at
the top of my freaking file?
It might be one of the plugins, to be
honest, Spencer, that's like gone stale
and trying to execute some dumb install.
>> Now we have to think about
So that's everything except the variable
num agents case, right?
And of course we'd like there algorithm
changes we can make.
Let me think if there's any reasonable
thing with variable agents or if it's
just screwed.
it's just so bad for everything, isn't
it?
I mean does anything really even use or
need that feature?
Like it's nice to have and there's some
cool problems you can study with it, but
like
such a pain in the ass.
Like I know how to do it actually to be
fair.
You just need separate sampling buffers.
I don't know if it's worth it.
The drive env, right?
Okay, but like if drive doesn't work
with state sets and it works with the
base 4.0,
that's still fine, isn't it?
No, you can't it's not empty agent or
max agent. You can't pad this one.
Doesn't work that way.
Spencer, how important is that for us?
If you think about it.
I think it's literally just drive right
now, right?
Is like having state sets in drive worth
maintaining a fancy ass buffer that has
like different sections?
you need to have a buffer for every
possible number of agents separate.
So, instead of having like one state
replay buffer, you now have one state
replay buffer for every different number
of agents that your environments have.
>> Just sharing part. No, it's not like a
how bad it is. It's like a this doesn't
even work. Like you can't even run it.
No, you can't state separate agent. That
doesn't make sense if you think about it
for a minute.
How do you use the same state for all
agents?
No, I mean the only thing that you'd be
able to do, Spencer,
is like you'd have to cap the number of
controlled agents in the scene.
And like you'd have to have you'd
basically have to just use say all the
scenes that have at least eight agents.
And any scenes that have more than eight
agents, you only control eight agents.
Some of it is shared, some is
individual.
You're going to screw stuff up that way,
man.
Mhm.
I mean, if you have a version of this
that you think makes sense, by all
means. I don't think that there is one.
Realistically as well, I think that once
you go above 10 agents,
um I think that the state set method as
a whole collapses.
So, this is really only going to be for
few agent ends.
We could pretty easily, I guess we could
make it so that um
the curriculum ends are the ones that
have a fixed number of agents and you
still have some other vanilla vanilla
training ends.
I guess we'll discuss this separately,
but
No, no, no, but like Spencer, 2 v 2
works, 3 v 3 works, like 1 v 1 works.
The only thing that you can't do is in
the same training run, have some M's
that have three agents and some M's that
have four agents and some that have two.
You see what I mean?
I think I'm it's better that I spend my
time on the algorithm core
and then we can sort of think about if
we need this later.
There's this, there's this, there's
this.
All right, let's let's think about the
core algorithm at this point.
State in the maze, the location and the
current maze shape. No, Spencer, it's
like everything here.
This is the state.
It has the maze.
It has all the stats. It's got the
current time, direction, position,
spawn. It's the whole maze.
Like the only stuff that isn't in the
state is the RNG, the data buffers, and
a couple constants.
Yeah, it's the whole shebang, except for
the RNG. We're very intentionally not
resetting you to the same RNG.
Though to be fair, I guess I would have
to ablate that.
Well, I think it's more interesting um
without the RNG.
All right, let's let's think a little
bit about the um
the algorithm here.
So,
at the moment, we have
pretty much all of the fresh
environments are just dumping their
states
into the state buffer.
Uh
every time you call rollout, Spencer.
So, you're getting the starting state of
every segment
for all of the fresh environments. You
don't log states that like curriculum
ends have gotten to.
I wonder what happens if we do both of
these stupid things.
Prioritize the prioritization.
You know?
>> It is kind of two different techniques,
huh?
Maybe we can prioritize the
prioritization, huh?
>> Okay, I have a couple experiments I want
to run based on this locally.
We'll see if this ends up being any
better or worse.
Dropping the state of the start of each
horizon. Yep, that's what I'm doing
Spencer.
I guess we could experiment with um
you know, if we wanted to randomize it
or shake it up a little bit, we didn't
want it to align to chunks of 64, I
could do a random state instead.
I think all the states is just too damn
many states.
But no, actually wait. No, there's a
reason for this Spencer. So the reason
for this is because you have a solid
advantage estimate of the first state,
right? You have to compute an advantage
estimate looking forward. That's why I
did it that way.
Cuz when we add stuff into the buffer,
it gets prioritized
based on the advantage estimate of it.
>> Yeah, so this looks like it's probably
slightly worse by one maze.
Oh. Nope, never mind.
It's going to be the same.
One in X roll out Carl's.
Um
I don't think it'll really help scaling
that much Spencer either way.
And the thing is you don't know which
ones that you actually need until um
until you compute the advantage.
And then there's also this whole bunch
of estimation bias crap to correct and
that makes it harder.
Well, 5 minutes for 45 scores pretty
damn good.
I wonder if it gets 47. I doubt it.
Be cool though.
Nope, I haven't watched anything yet
Spencer. I'm pretty confident in this
end overall.
Um I have not watched it yet though.
Kind of thinking in algo space at the
moment.
I'm trying to think about the whole
important sampling bias thing.
as the other ones. But at the very least
it seems like the double priority thing
doesn't hurt.
>> All right, here's the next thing I
wanted to try, right?
So, I have this prior alpha prior beta.
This, I think you do need this for
important sampling, right?
I wonder if you need this beta though.
Like, do you really need
Go look at the uh the biases in this
paper.
How they introduce their important
sample thing.
How do you confidently determine
algorithmic performance from small
changes unless you do a large sweep of
params
on training runs. We do a large sweep of
params on training runs.
That's how we do it.
We run like 20,000 experiments.
This is basically like I'm fairly
confident that the analysis I'm doing
here is correct, but like I also have
sweep a sweep going in the background
and I'll launch another one tonight. You
know, I have a sweep going for the
baseline.
And then uh we'll have a sweep set up
for this environment.
Oh, holy crap. Wait, we're at 45 score
in a minute and a half.
Huh?
That answers the that Yeah, Teddy, we
literally we run more RL experiments
than anybody else.
Have you seen constellation?
I'm super proud of this thing.
This just runs in your browser.
And this has data for all of our ends.
All interactive, you can click it, you
can filter it by all sorts of different
values.
It's super fast, it has all the data
from Puffer 4 experiments. This is how
we do stuff.
Well, I just guessed Hypers and then
this thing um
solved in a minute and a half at 45.
There's technically one more map it can
get.
It gets a reward after each stage, Arch.
Reward after each like maze would
probably just be impossible. I think
that's impossible for almost anything.
I think that this is a better way to
correct than um
than the important sampling is.
So, we'll see.
You guys get what I'm doing with this?
So,
normally you would have this important
sampling correction.
We're going to set this to zero and
instead we're going to anneal the
curriculum M so that um we end up with
zero by the end of training. So, we're
going to end up basically having the
train distribution end up the same as
regular.
There are a few ways that this could
mess up.
So, I actually
I won't be surprised by any result here.
Like this could work and this could flip
fail completely.
I do hope we get a strong result one way
or the other though. I hope we don't end
up at 43 or some [ __ ]
There are a couple more experiments we
can run in here.
I'm going to try this one.
Cuz it occurs to me that we were in
yielding exploration beta before.
We will watch this.
It is converging back actually to
something better.
Uh the reason I want to watch this run
is I want to see if it gets more
unstable towards the end or something.
It's having a very hard time here
getting the 43.
I wouldn't be surprised if that's
because it no longer has enough N's.
Oh, and now it just jumps to 45. Okay.
Maybe I'm wrong. Let's see if it gets
47.
I don't think it will though. My
prediction is that it gets unstable
towards the end of training because it
doesn't have enough curriculum ends.
Of course the puffer is sentient. It's a
puffer fish.
They're quite friendly and intelligent.
Huh?
Are we getting unstable?
A little bit of entropy left. It could
technically still solve it.
But like right now it has maybe 30%
curriculum ends.
X audio is delayed. If X audio is
delayed, that is on X.
What's the score based on?
Um so this is the average size maze this
should be at least the average size maze
that the agents are completing.
So flat on 45 should mean that
essentially all the agents are
completing 45 by 45 and then failing
on the 47 by 47.
Uh ooh, that is a little bit of signal
right there.
There is actually a little bit of signal
above 45.
I've one more experiment to try after
this as well.
47. Ho ho!
Look at that, folks.
That's solved.
Up, and then score goes to zero.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh, that's wonderful.
Yeah, so this is, um,
it going to zero is what happens when
you anneal,
um,
yeah, that's what happens when you
anneal out the clip fraction.
For the, uh, the CL frac.
All right, I'm going to try this again
without annealing the CL frac, and we're
going to see if this works.
It got to 47 by 47, and then what
happened there? So, 47 by 47 is a
really, really long set, like that's a
really long set of M's. And it had
basically no curriculum M's left either.
It's basically running from scratch all
the M's up to 47.
So, uh, it did that, and then by the
time it finishes the 47 by 47, it no
longer knows how to do the earlier M's,
because it wasn't getting any early
data.
I mean, so this is pretty solid evidence
that you don't want to anneal the CL
frag.
So then it's just a question of whether
you anneal beta or not.
We'll go double-check the logging real
quick.
Removed all consumables and it soda'd.
>> [laughter]
>> That's funny, John. I actually I did
something similar with Volo and it
didn't soda, but it basically did just
as well on the Inferno with no supplies
as with all supplies.
So I kept um I think I kept the
restores.
Cuz I don't I forget if you can actually
prayer flick in our version of it.
I don't think you can prayer flick. Like
a um one tick flick, I mean.
How quickly you can do breakout? It's
not going to be any faster, Jess, I
don't think.
I mean, we can try it, but like
it's going to need to be retuned and
then this algorithm is not going to help
every end.
It might help breakout actually.
You know, come to think of it, it
actually might help breakout.
All right, so regardless of whether this
gets 47,
this should be way more stable towards
the end than the other one.
I wouldn't be surprised if all we need
to do to solve this anyways is just
increase the entropy a little bit.
I want to see what this gets though.
One to two solves per second.
That's fun.
While your language model does one to
two steps per second on breakout, we
solve it at one to two times per second.
Yeah, that's great.
>> Actually,
um hang on. I think this works, right?
Hm.
The important sampling's a little
sketchy, actually, to be fair. I I'm not
sure.
Oh, there you go. That's 47.
That's 47 and 3/40. Like, yeah, that's
perfect.
Okay.
I mean, that's [ __ ] ridiculous, isn't
it?
The cool thing about this result, if you
think about it,
is we actually are not even going to
need to wait for um
another sweep, right?
Like, we don't even need to wait for
another sweep.
All we need to do is know if the
baseline can get this in 4 minutes.
Maze never maxed out. This is maxed. It
only generates to 47.
>> [laughter]
>> Spencer messages me like, I eat some
chicken parm and you solve RL, what the
[ __ ]
>> [laughter]
>> We do have to eval this.
But, um, this should be better than
like any of the other maze policies. I
guess, of course, we still have to run
this on
You know, why don't we just run this on
the normal mazes just to see how well it
does?
I'm kind of curious.
I mean, this learns a full to turn
policy, of course.
>> It'd be even funnier if we made it like
um every single maze ramps up.
We'll keep the benchmark this way for
now though.
I thought that we had a a little script
for this, didn't we?
Now, if this soda's
like
we just win.
Pop for five is ready. We ship it
tomorrow. Now, we don't quite ship it
tomorrow, but like we literally could if
we want to if this works.
Uh ooh, actually let's let's try this
end We'll try both end co-offs.
Some random puffer art.
Yeah, look at this.
I'll have patience with this one.
Um and then we'll see what the entropy
of this needs to be bumped for the new
algo or not.
Okay, it is training. It just took a
while to get started.
But that could be learning rate
annealing, that could be many things.
But we'll see how this does.
It'll be interesting.
I also have just arbitrarily set 80% of
the environments to be uh curriculum
members at this point. That might not be
the right number.
That was a really stupid stream,
Jonathan. It's kind of unfortunate
that's my most watched stream. I mean,
it was intentionally stupid, but
intentionally stupid is still stupid.
Um the models have gotten better and I
don't remotely use them in the way that
I like did for that dumb stream.
So, better models combined with
controlled usage is producing some nice
results.
Um and it's actually producing usable
code, at least when I am
very heavily monitoring and manually
adding things.
And uh the people saying I told you so a
year ago, like the models just sucked
even worse a year ago. They're just bad
programmers.
Like it's kind of funny in this case.
The The early adopters are just the
really bad programmers because the
earlier models were just like way better
than they were at programming, which is
kind of sad.
Um the models are still bad at
programming, but
like they're quite quick and useful and
they don't make um
a lot of like basic syntax errors.
And uh you know, or syntax and usage
errors.
They make more just like architecture
and decision and implementation errors,
which are
uh that at that level I can very
precisely describe what I need.
Okay, I'm very curious to see how well
this thing is going to do though.
It's very, very close to being on par
with before.
And this is just me guessing the prio
coefficient, basically.
>> I think it's going to just be on par,
not better.
>> Yeah.
It's just about the same.
Well, we get to sweep this still and
this is not the end of to test on.
That's really not to test on, so that's
not too disappointing.
Um the fact that this doesn't make it
worse though is uh is good.
>> I think I have headless rendering
working.
That's nice. Oh yeah, I'll summarize in
a sec, Jess. Export frames into a folder
and then I need to stitch them together.
Wait, do you have to do that, Arch?
I didn't think you have to do it that
way.
We have in the drive env already, like
you can pipe I think you should just be
able to pipe the output to ffmpeg
directly and have it be way faster than
stitching.
Beat me to it, Joseph.
Yeah. So, um Jess, so far today, we have
implemented and refined the
GoPuff
uh algorithm, which combines GoExplore
style state sets with uh prioritized
experience replay, but over the starting
states that you use.
Um
fixed a whole bunch of problems with the
algorithms, gotten it implemented
correctly at least for fixed numbers of
agents in multi-agent environments.
Uh we have made a version of the maze
end that is better suited to test this.
We have very, very good results on that,
which so far I have not seen
um any configuration of the 4.0
algorithm come anywhere close to.
Uh I'm currently checking what the sweep
has produced on that so far, cuz we're
doing that now. We've also refactored
puffer to use a single uh compilation
unit instead of a C build and an NVCC
build.
Um Nvidia like a CUDA build.
And uh that cost us maybe 2 to 3% perf,
but lets us dramatically simplify a
bunch of the really jank stuff in the
code. And we should be able to optimize
that back with some new things that we
can do now that we have it this way as
well.
Whatever the stupid script, we don't
care.
Maybe this thing has found something
good.
Okay, it did find something good, but it
takes
Interesting though, it did find
something.
With probably a very big model,
actually.
So, interesting that it is able to solve
this task in 4O with a gigantic freaking
model.
Oh, but not fully solved, right? This is
still not even This is not 47.
193 experiments so far as well.
Well, this will be interesting, right?
I'm actually very surprised that we're
able to do this at all with them.
That's crazy that that's actually able
to do that.
with a puffer four
I mean, if you think about that, that's
like
a single example up to each maze size.
Huh.
>> How many unique mazes does it train on?
Uh
I believe like 23 or 24, Ryan.
It basically it has to
It has to Oh, did you just get here?
Um
I think we solved curriculum learning
today.
It has to solve a 5 by 5, then a 7 by 7,
9 by 9, so on and so forth.
So, Ryan, um
in 4 minutes, we are able to train
an agent that will in a row solve
5 by 5, 7 by 7, da da da da da da, all
the way up to 47 by 47,
which was the previous largest maze that
we were training in the like the nicely
randomized setting.
We do have one version of Puffer It
looks to me like we have one run so far
um from a 200 run sweep in Puffer 4 that
is able to do it,
but that one takes
Well, it's actually not that many steps,
but that one has a massive model.
This is
How big is this model? It's like a 20
million plus parameter model.
And it mostly memorizes it's sparse,
dude.
It has to randomly like it only gets a
reward at the end of each maze that it
solves. And if it runs out of time on
any individual maze, it gets sent all
the way back to the start.
So, it's a 9,000 it's a 9,000 episode
length task
with only like 24-ish intermediate
rewards.
And it gets increasingly sparse the
farther you get.
Progressively memorizing. Right, but
like if you do this from scratch, you
won't ever solve a 47 by 47. Like you
can run it for a billion steps and you
just don't get the reward.
Go explore can solve that pretty
quickly. No, it can't.
You need a heuristic.
Right?
Go explore has um
it does it Go explore uses an archive as
the heuristic.
Right? And they'll like down sample the
maze or whatever or they come up with or
they'll use like XY.
This doesn't have a domain specific
heuristic at all.
Where do you see the mazes for go
explore?
Well then wait, how are you getting any
signal?
One-to-one state to cell mapping?
Oh wait, so you'd be deduping it then,
right? Uh
But then you're basically you're
exploiting the fact that there only so
many observations,
right?
Because otherwise with that if you add a
tiny amount of noise,
then you just have massive blow up of
states.
I think this is still more general, man.
This literally only uses advantage.
That's basically what you're doing with
a full state buffer. I'm not No, it's
not. That's the thing. So what I'm doing
is every so every so often you just take
the current state and you stick it into
a buffer. There's no deduping, there's
no like assumption that obs corresponds
to like there's none of that.
The only metric that is being used to
sample from that buffer
is advantage.
In fact, the states never even go on to
the GPU. The states just stay on the
CPU. The only thing that you need the
states for is to set the environment.
Like I'll go never even directly sees
the states.
Isn't it randomly generating a maze
every time? Not in this version of the
task arch. We made a version of this
task for states that exploration stuff.
One-to-one state to cell mapping, that
is interesting though.
That strategy is uniquely good for
mazes.
No, no, no. The thing that I'm doing is
not uniquely good for mazes at all. Like
for instance,
um we want to throw this on uh Valo has
the Inferno sim, and John has the Fight
Cave sim. Both of those are like, you
know, very long tasks. Fight Cave's
maybe 40 minutes, Inferno like an hour
and a half.
And um
you know, you have an unlimited number
of states and observations effectively
with those, and this will work.
Where you can't afford to sort search
for No, no, no, it's not. That's the
thing, Ryan. It's not bad. Like it
doesn't have that problem. That's my
point.
Cuz you're not searching from every
state. Right? In fact, I've tested this,
and this doesn't help at all if you use
uniform sampling from the state buffer.
The key to it is that you're using
advantage as the metric for prior
replay.
You're taking You have a uniform buffer
of states, like a ring buffer, but you
are doing biased sampling in a fully
general way.
And it's also basically no performance
overhead whatsoever.
Actually, I wonder if the current
version is performance overhead. Cuz I
know it won't be if I optimize it. Let
me see if I can do breakout. This
probably won't solve breakout with
default Hypers.
Yeah, so that is the key, Ryan. It only
helps so this is yes, this is the one
limitation, right? This solves a portion
of exploration.
Um I actually I think it does solve
curriculum learning in the sense that
you're assuming like there is a
curriculum that there is a signal.
Um the only remaining thing in
exploration would be like state
coverage. This does not solve state
coverage on its own.
So in a state like in an env that's
purely based on state coverage, you
could have no reward at all in the env
and still want the agent to cover
states.
Exploration is hard. I he keeps saying
solving curriculum learning. Well, the
thing is in my mind, so
curriculum is you have
like there's an ordering to things
presented in some way with signal,
right? I think exploration is broader
than curriculum learning
because exploration also includes state
coverage. This doesn't solve state
coverage.
And the reason I would say that I think
that this solves is because like state
sets is just about the most powerful
technique you can use, right?
Like you can probably show like there
are problems that you just do not solve
with anything that does not use state
coverage in a reasonable amount of time.
I mean state sets in a reasonable amount
of time.
Curriculum learning is much broader than
setting states, but I think that setting
states is just about the most powerful
technique you can use. Like there are
problems you can demonstrate that you
cannot solve any way other than setting
states in a reasonable
amount of time.
It would want to even solve state
coverage effectively. That's hard. Um we
I have some ideas, but I think that's
going to be like an additional algorithm
change.
Oh yeah, Ryan. I also have a giant
Piplup if you want one.
Probably the reason you need state sets.
Yeah, but it really in my mind it's not
like it doesn't matter that a human can
solve those examples quickly.
Like having pattern recognition baked
in, like that doesn't help. How big?
Oh, cool.
Uh two to three weeks. Yeah, I'll be
around. How big?
Like two and a half feet maybe tall?
Couple feet wide.
It's a chunker.
It's free though. I got to get rid of it
and I've been saving it for somebody who
would appreciate it.
I don't think I could take that on a
plane.
I mean, I'll ship it to you.
>> [laughter]
>> Deal.
Sounds good.
And we'll see whether you think I've
solved um
the L by then.
I mean, like even if I do, it is based
on your lab's work, isn't it?
So.
9 months?
Okay.
Awesome.
I have been thinking about this
algorithm for quite a while, I will say.
Like, this is not just I did this in a
day. Like, this has been an algorithm
I've I sketched this out um last week.
But like, I've been thinking about this
algorithm for a long time.
Oof. Okay. This hurts right here. This
takes us down to 15 mil SPS.
Presumably, we can make this faster,
though.
Yeah, I I actually One thing I could
experiment with I'm using the absolute
value of advantage right now. So, you
get like really good and really bad
outcomes. It's inspired by the Giga flow
paper, you know, where they do the the
sampling.
And um inspired by also like my own
stuff on Popper 3
where we did prioritized experience
replay combined with this advantage
filtering stuff.
So, I mean this has been in
the works for a while as well in some
sense.
Right. They're all a tiny change from
pure advantage.
Yeah, I will have to ask you about that
cuz I have I don't know anything about
that area
at all.
Oh, you know what? I I bet I bet I know
why this is slow.
I bet you that if I do warm up
I bet you if I do like this, I bet you
it immediately is fast.
Okay, a little bit faster. So, there's
something stupid and slow in here.
Okay, that does solve, though.
Um, I don't think this improves stuff
yet, though.
In the original paper,
it's abs of advantage.
Or max of zero and Oh, wait, is that
literally what it is?
Abs of advantage, I got that separately
from giga flow.
Max zero and advantage.
Okay.
Yeah, uh, current one I'm using should
be abs of advantage, which is what also
we use that for, um,
prioritized experience replay.
Well, it's not exactly prioritized
experience replay, but like the sampling
thing we do with puffer three.
We have that.
What time is it? 5:30?
I have about half an hour.
Oh, yeah. One other funny thing I'm
doing Ryan is um
I'm intentionally
not setting the RNG of the environment
via state.
So, state is decoupled from RNG.
So, when you return to a state like
dynamics can be different from there.
What's puffing?
>> [laughter]
>> Uh Go explore research is puffing.
Oh, man. You have to link me that
non-clickable
So I guess our version is closest to J
E, right? But it's not actually J E,
it's puffer advantage.
J E is best on this one.
Min margin.
Yeah, so J E is basically near the top
here. They have one step TD for some
reason that's also good.
Um
We already have J E computed, so I think
we can just use that.
L1 value
is the best.
Wait, no, it's isn't this the worst? L1
value is the worst, isn't it?
Yeah, L1 value is the worst.
And then
Wait, why do they have two plots with
all averaged?
Wait, what?
Hang on.
Why why do they have their plots like
this?
Wait, one.
Uh
ELR rank P
Wait, so JE is the best here.
And then min margin is the best here.
But like they don't give me an average
over a bunch of ends with these, do
they?
These are very noisy. Like look, it's
completely different across two ends.
Does them quickly.
Fair enough.
Well, we will be able to discuss if
you're here in a couple weeks.
Margarita's on me.
Salt, miss salt.
They basically should sell me a meal
plan at this point, man. I'm doing a
1,000 plus calorie cut at the moment.
And it's basically I just eat soup.
I just run and I eat soup. That's all I
do.
What other N can I test this on you
think? I guess like
maybe
2048 would be a good N.
I think 2048 would be a really good N
for curriculum, right?
Yeah, I think yeah, 2048 cuz you have to
get through the whole damn game
otherwise, right?
I've been using minihack.
Yeah.
If we can port NetHack to actually be
fast finally,
then maybe. But like with 20 mil step
per second training now,
we're kind of just using our own ends.
You know, these are the ones we have at
the moment. We've got a few more ones we
can merge.
Yeah, I think of all of these the only
one that stands out to me as a really
good candidate is
um 2048.
Go is kind of too messy, and it's a
self-play env. We will throw it on chess
because we already have a way bigger
active project on chess.
And this is really easy to do.
State sets on.
Oh, that's you Jess. So yeah, obviously
we'll do on chess for you.
I thought that was Ryan.
You just mess with the reward function
for some like make Pac-Man sparse.
Um
Yeah.
Maybe.
What do you think the main blockers are?
Should be faster refactor.
I don't even know if you need to
refactor the NetHack code base. You
basically you just need to get the like
figure out what chunks of the the the
bindings that are in NLE, you actually
need to make it work.
Um what obs you actually really need,
ideally flat obs if you can get away
with them, like not gigantic obs,
and then get it bound at the C level to
Python's
to Puffer's N VPI and see how fast it is
from there.
I would very, very happily take a PR for
that.
Yeah, just but the go policy we have is
like eh.
You give it a try? I look forward to
seeing it.
Yeah, I think if we can get the obs down
to a reasonable enough size,
it's a little tricky because it's these
like the obs are glyphs.
>> Honestly, I don't really think there's a
problem with just using mazes for now,
Ryan, for the research.
Um once I have this stable and I'm happy
with it on mazes, I'm going to test it
like we have the the whole Runescape
Inferno.
Like that'll be a really good end. If
that thing takes more than an hour.
And that's not mazes. That's like 61
increasingly difficult levels that you
have to do in sequence.
Yeah.
I mean, this is the cool thing with the
puffer ends, right? Like we actually
have some pretty heavy hitting ends
that we can use and they're fast.
Runescape's very different. So, the
funny thing is even with puffer four,
we're kind of already mostly beating it.
Um
Puffer 4 is quite good.
I think you can do it much faster and
with it like less hacking because we do
have a couple like manual curriculum
points in it at the moment. But I think
we can probably do it without them.
No more problems to solve.
Uh we will still have problems to solve.
Um Ryan, eventually I'm just going to
like start doing low-level molecular
samplers and [ __ ]
What resources used when I was a
beginner to strengthen your arm
concepts? I mostly used the resource of
bashing my head against crap.
Uh luckily, you can do better than that.
And I've made a bunch of things to help.
If you just go to my X
and articles
these two articles right here are your
best friend.
And there are a bunch of other research
articles there as well.
But coupled with you trying to get a
biochem degree in a year?
I mean, I am kind of right by Stanford
here. And like a year is so long, man.
Why don't we just do it in the summer?
The be a little tricky. You kind of have
to take the
intro course before you take the
advanced course.
You could probably do it in a year.
Like you can do CS in a year. Hell, I
did CS in a year, right?
At least the core of it.
And some grad stuff.
Hey, you can do it in a year.
See, Ryan?
I don't know if you can do a fast sample
without replacement, though.
See, this is where we start adding a
bunch of garbage very quickly if we're
not careful.
I have to order
some food on the side here.
>> Uh.
That is done.
Uh, 2048 actually does make sense as an
N.
The spacing of the um
progression is quite aggressive, though.
Oh, it did find. Look at this. It found
a 47 solve.
But it found a massive
massive policy.
This is not that bad though. This is 10
minutes. Hmm.
Yeah, it gets exponentially harder to
solve and it takes like twice as many
moves, right? Cuz the wait, it gets
double the size, so it takes twice as
many moves.
Whereas the mazes only take a few more
moves to solve.
It's quadratic number of moves.
It's going to be very interesting to run
the sweep
versus this.
The actual 47 I'll believe will be a
little volatile.
Oh, yeah, you can't name [ __ ] min and
max.
Fix that later.
As this is 45.
Look at that. Prior alpha set to one in
G2048.
All right.
Um
>> Okay.
We have this done.
All I have to do is
run an extra experiment or two on this.
And
we'll see how many runs I want to do on
this.
Um
I guess
what's a good number to do?
Let's add 200 runs, I guess, like before
I go to sleep, maybe 300 runs.
I'd really like to have the the new one
swept overnight.
Tomorrow's agenda is puff for five dev.
I'm going to basically mull over the
results and think about what I want to
do next.
Follow is going to be playing with it on
Inferno tomorrow.
You'll be playing with it on chess
whenever you feel like. Latest stuff is
all pushed.
Fix any small things as you see them.
Time is it? 6:07.
I got to head for dinner in a few.
Um
I think that's kind of it. I think I
just call it here, guys.
Yeah, I think I just call it here.
And we'll pick this back up tomorrow.
Hey, muffin.
This is some very solid progress, I
suppose.
We're going to have to see based on the
sweep.
From what I've seen though so far,
even though this thing is finding
solves, it's finding like giant net slow
solves.
But I think they're still going to be
massive, massive lift.
Okay.
Um, for folks watching, thank you for
joining in day one of the Puffer 5 dev.
Uh, if you'd like to support my work for
absolutely free, star the Puffer on
GitHub. Helps that a lot.
And join Discord to get involved. This
is all open source free work.
And you can follow me on X for more
reinforcement learning content. If you
happen to be at a company doing RL and
would like our assistance professionally
in custom R&D or in simulation
development, uh, you can drop me an
email.